so you've also
have developed yourself some elegant
beautiful algorithms
again picking your children so the the
the
robin carp algorithm for string
searching pattern matching
admin carp algorithm for max flows we
mentioned hop craft carbon algorithm for
finding
maximum cardinality matchings and
bipartite graphs
is there ones that stand out to you as
ones you're most proud of or just um
whether it's beauty elegance or
just being the right discovery
development in your life
that you're especially proud of i like
the
ravencarp algorithm because it
illustrates the power of
randomization
so the
the problem there is to
is to decide whether uh
a given long string of symbols from some
alphabet contains a given word
whether a particular word occurs within
some very
much longer word and so the
the idea of the um
algorithm is to associate
with the word that we're looking for
a fingerprint some
some number or some
combinatorial object that
describes that word and then to look for
an occurrence of that same fingerprint
as you slide along the longer word
and what we do is we
associate with each word a number
so we first of all we think of the
letters that are gonna occur in a word
as the digits of let's say decimal
or whatever base here
whatever number of different symbols
there are
that's the base of the of the numbers
yeah right
so every word can then be thought of as
a number with
the letters being the digits of that
number
and then we pick a random prime number
in a certain range
and we take that word viewed as a number
and take the remainder on dividing
dividing that number by the prime
so coming up with a nice hash function
it's a it's a kind of hash function
yeah um it gives you a little little
shortcut for for that particular word
yeah
so that's the that's the uh it's very
different than the
any and other algorithms of its kind
that we're trying to do search uh string
matching yeah which usually are
combinatorial and don't
involve the idea of taking a random
fingerprint
yes and doing the fingerprinting has
two advantages one is that as we slide
along the long word
digit by digit we can we we keep
a window of of a certain size the size
of the
word we're looking for and we we
compute the fingerprint of every
stretch of that length and it turns out
that
just a couple of arithmetic operations
will take you
from the fingerprint of one part
to what you get when you slide over by
one position
so the computation of all the
fingerprints
is um simple
and secondly it's unlikely if the
prime is chosen randomly from a certain
range
that you will get two of the segments
in question having the same fingerprint
right and so there's a small probability
of error which can be checked after the
fact
and also the ease of doing the
computation because you're working with
these fingerprints
which are remainders modulo some big
prime
so that's the magical thing about
randomized algorithms is that if you add
a little bit
of uh randomness it somehow allows you
to take a pretty naive approach
a simple looking approach and allow it
to run
extremely well so can you maybe
take a step back and say like what is a
randomized algorithm this category of
algorithms
well it's um just the ability to draw
a random number from such um from some
range or to
uh to associate a random number with
some object
or to draw fr at random from some set
so uh another
example is um very simple if we're
conducting a presidential election
and we would like to pick the winner
in principle we could draw
a random sample of all of the voters in
the country
and if it was a side of substantial size
say a few thousand
then the most popular candidate in that
group
would be very likely to be the correct
choice that would come out of counting
all the millions of votes
of course we can't do this because first
of all everybody has to feel that his or
her vote counted
and secondly we can't really do a purely
random sample
from that population and i guess thirdly
there could be a tie in which case
we wouldn't have a significant
difference between two candidates
but those things aside if you didn't
have all that messiness of human beings
you could prove that that kind of random
picking would be just that random
picking
would would be uh would solve the
problem with a very
with a very low probability of error
another example is
testing whether a number is prime so if
i want to test whether
[Music]
17 is prime
i could pick any number between
1 and 17 and raised it to the
16th power modulo 17 and you should get
back the original number
that's a famous uh formula due to ferma
about it's called fairmont's little
theorem that
um if you take any a any number
a in the range
0 through n minus 1 and raise it to the
n minus 1 power
modulo n you'll get back the number a
if the number is if a is prime yeah so
if you don't get back the number a
that's a proof that a number is not
prime
well and
you can show that
suitably define the the
the probability that you will get
uh a value unequaled
you will get a violation of fairmont's
result
is very high and so this gives you a way
of
rapidly proving that a number is not
prime
it's a little more complicated than that
because there are certain
values of n where something a little
more elaborate has to be done but that's
the basic idea
using taking an identity that holds for
primes and therefore
if it ever fails on any instance
for a non-prime unit you know that the
number is not prime it's a quick joy
a fast choice fast proof that a number
is not prime
can you maybe elaborate a little bit
more what's your intuition why
randomness works so well
and results in such simple algorithms
well uh the example of conducting an
election where you could
take in in theory you could take a
sample and depend on the
validity of the sample to really
represent the whole
is it just the basic fact of statistics
which gives
a lot of opportunities um
and uh i actually exploited that sort of
random
random sampling idea in uh
designing an algorithm for uh counting
the number of solutions
that satisfy a particular
formula and propositional calc
propositional logic
a particular so some some some uh
version of the satisfiability problem or
a version of the satisfiability problem
is there some interesting insight that
you want to elaborate on like what
what some aspect of that algorithm that
might be
useful to describe so you you have a
a collection of
formulas and you want
to count the
number of solutions
that satisfy at least one of the
formulas
and you can count the number of
solutions that satisfy
any particular one of the formulas but
you have to account
for the fact that that solution might be
counted many times if it solves
more than one of the formulas
and so what you do is you
sample from the formulas according to
the number
of solutions that satisfy each
individual one
in that way you draw a random solution
but then you correct
by looking at the number of formulas
that satisfy that random solution
and uh and don't double count
so if if you you can think of it this
way so you have a
matrix of zeros and ones and you want to
know
how many columns of that matrix contain
at least one one
and you can count in each row how many
ones there are
so what you can do is draw from the rows
according to
the number of ones if a row has more
ones it gets to run
more frequently but then
if you draw from that row you have to go
up the column and looking at
where that same one is repeated in
different rows
and only count it as a success
or a hit if it's the earliest row that
contains the one
right and that gives you a
robust statistical estimate of the total
number of columns that contain at least
one of the ones
so that that is an example of
the same principle that was used in
studying random sampling
another viewpoint is that
if you have a phenomenon that occurs
almost all the time
then if you sample one of the
occasions where it occurs you're most
likely to
and you're looking for an occurrence a
random occurrence is likely to work
so that comes up in solving
identities solving algebraic identities
you get two formulas that may look very
different you want to know if they're
really identical
what you can what you can do is just
pick a random value and evaluate the
formulas at those
two at that value and see if they seeing
if they agree
and you depend on the fact
that if the formulas are distinct then
they're going to disagree a lot
and so therefore a random choice will
exhibit the disagreement
if there are many ways for the two to
disagree
and you only need to find one
disagreement then random choice
is likely to yield it
you